[Music]
before the Lamborghini distracted me Oh
probably something Astrophysical so once
you have computers come here say Howard
became good enough yeah so that you can
track what stars are going to do in one
system versus another and it's not a
trivial exercise because every star is
pulling on every other star at all times
mm-hmm so you can you can say okay in
this instant where will every star go
you move it a little bit now every
source at a different position
so the pulling differently on every
other star so now you sum up all the
gravity vectors and then you increment
the movement of every single object and
a computer was able to do that beginning
in the 1970s and when we did that what
we found was that this catalog of
peculiar galaxies of disturbed galaxies
represented all stages of the collision
and merger of pairs and in some cases
three triple galaxy systems and so so
you can say well what is that well
that's what this looks like after 200
million years all right
there's like a stream of stars this way
and that way what is that
that's one after three hundred million
years and the system starts collapsing
back so right that sequence of evolution
shapes morphologies of galaxies yeah is
called the tumor a sequence the tomb rat
oom ray named after Yuri and a large
tomb ray who were the pioneers in using
computers to figure out that indeed
collisions and interactions between
galaxies would create these funny shapes